it is ridiculous that we have
chronically under built for 30 years
gentrification is colonization it's a
monoculture [ __ ] city people are
happy to see jobs they're not happy to
see people move into their neighborhood
they know that where we have run out and
they do not care San Francisco is one of
America's most expensive cities and it's
become the symbol of the nation's
housing crisis last year the Bay Area
added 64,000 jobs but built less than
5,000 new housing units years of this
type of chronic under building has led
to skyrocketing real estate prices and
runs the median home price is now over
the million dollar mark in an average
one-bedroom apartment rents for more
than $3,500 a month
I got priced out I moved couldn't afford
to rent if so many people are getting
priced out of a market that doesn't have
enough housing why not just build more
housing it seems like a simple idea one
so obvious that free market libertarians
and regulation friendly progressives
agreeing on it so why can't San
Francisco get it done the project is an
embarrassment it's a travesty and
abomination I'm feeling so violated
NIMBYs who say not in my backyard have
successfully organized against
development in the region for decades by
blocking new housing construction needed
to meet demand bit by bit
citizens have put together this you know
system of permissions and regulation but
there's a new counterweight to the
NIMBYs that are getting noticed by the
media activists who are saying yes to
new development they indeed
Sonia trows is one of the most visible
members of the ENB movement
she began her activism by writing
letters to local officials and
commiserating with friends talking to
your friends about politics is fine but
I just felt like we should go make these
speeches in front of someone who's
actually about to make a decision so the
self-described anarchists took action
and created the San Francisco Bay Area
renters Federation its mission to
support laws that make it easier to
build and to change the political
structure of a city where any small
group of people can derail a private
project they deemed to be a nuisance we
are embarking on a public conversation
about property rights and where should
they be situated because currently the
way property rights are is you can't do
that much to your property you don't
have that much control over it but you
have a lot of control over everyone
else's around you we want to switch the
regime to you having a lot of control
over your own property but not that much
over people next to you the yin B
movement is attracting people from all
political persuasions they're mostly
young professionals trying to counter
opponents who say more development will
make San Francisco lose its soul I agree
with all of those folks that are saying
that the culture here is being destroyed
gentrification is colonisation and while
good old-fashioned NIMBYism plays a role
in the current crisis developers face
another major opposition force in San
Francisco well-intentioned progressives
who want to help the poor by only
allowing certain kinds of housing to be
built we don't need any more luxury
housing we need affordable housing and
we need to build in tens of thousands of
units but there's a problem with this
approach as well and it comes down to
the basic principle of scarcity in a
tight housing market like San Francisco
low income middle-class and wealthy
residents are competing with each other
for the same units building new
market-rate housing helps ease this
competition by adding more supply the
idea being that today's luxury condo
becomes future affordable housing what
we need is a ton of housing and in this
case I think the market is the only
institution that is able to build the
housing that we need
but these NIMBYs contend that the
private market doesn't work the private
market will not provide the housing
needed for the majority of residents in
San Francisco economics folks are saying
over and over supply and demand it
doesn't really apply here it's not
really working let's try something else
it's not even supply and demand it's
like have you ever had the experience of
trying to stuff a lot of stuff in a
suitcase right have you ever gone to a
party and seeing that the pizza was gone
but you still wanted some I mean it's
just a it's just running out and they
know that we're we have run out and they
do not care a lot of people who want to
control development absolutely want to
control the people here you know and
they are absolutely thinking that if we
don't build then the type of people I
don't like won't be able to come and
that is such an anastomotic me like
that's not America that's not California
but the severity of the housing crisis
is swinging public policy in favor of
the eunbi's in May Sonya and her fellow
housing activists visited the State
Capitol to walk the halls and meet with
legislators in support of Governor Jerry
Brown's latest proposal that would
streamline the permitting process for
new housing to prevent NIMBYs from
stalling proposed residential projects
we have a system right now where we have
established the rules of zoning and
instead of you follow the rules you get
your permits we have a system where you
follow the rules and then you go through
multiple bureaucratic hurdles Laura
Clark is president of gross San
Francisco a group that favors the new
legislation if you have anyone who
opposes your project they can pull
multiple roadblocks in front of it some
of the developments NIMBYs have stalled
include 1979 Mission Street attends
storey condo development that been in
Dee's dubbed the monster in the mission
a 17 acre space at Balboa Reservoir
where residents would prefer to have an
empty parking lot instead of housing and
a 36 storey residential building at 1481
post which has been negotiated for over
10 years laura has witnessed this
process in her own neighborhood so they
were gonna take this kind of crappy cute
little cottage and turn it into a
two-story two unit building
exactly like every other building and
their neighbors who have a two-story
building next door decided that they
hated that because it was going to block
the light and air into their units and
so they went around and for about the
like six or ten blocks in the
surrounding radius put a nasty gram into
everybody's mailbox saying come out to
the Planning Commission and tell them
that this kind of stuff is going to
destroy our community and I filled me
with rage and I was like this is why we
have a crisis is because each one of
these little one unit projects is
getting scuttled by the neighbors that
project still hasn't been built Ginn
bees say that by opposing any new
development NIM bees are just adding to
the housing problems of the very people
they're trying to help they contend that
you can't advocate for both higher
property values and affordable units you
know I've heard progressives say well
the solution to this is we need to tank
the economy that seems like a bad plan
to me I think that we can be more
creative than that I think that we can
solve our housing crisis and have
working people be able to live in the
city again the young bees will be
holding their first national conference
this June in Boulder Colorado and Sonia
is scheduled to be one of the keynote
speakers at the event her goal is to
export the MV platform to other cities
experiencing housing issues and to
create a property rights regime that
favors the landowner NIMBYs have the
advantage they're very decentralized you
know they see a project go up and
suddenly they're activated you know
they're like we know what to do I want
um used to be like that too you know
decentralized we need to let them know
loud and clear that there is a loud
constituency that truly believes that we
need to solve this crisis by adding more
housing in the Bay Area if we do not get
that message to them they will continue
to think that the only voting block that
matters are people who oppose housing
cities aren't incredible things there
are places where freedom is possible in
a way that it's just not as possible in
a small town diversity is possible so I
feel like San Francisco in the Bay Area
should be taking advantage of its
opportunity to build a big city